bonjour à tous la cour aujourd'hui
s'intéressent à la personnalité des deux
accusés et elle a commencé par rémy qq
lorsqu'il ce matin c'est sa meilleure
amie qui a été appelé à la barre et on
peut que constater que le profil de ce
jeune homme est assez noir une enfance
difficile une adolescence mouvementée
rémy venait tout juste de sortir de
prison un mois avant le drame pour avoir
agressé quelqu'un à l'armé blanche à
semur-en-auxois rémi kukulinski était
alors âgé de 18 ans il était sdf je vous
propose d'écouter la réaction de son
avocate oui il a un parcours
très particulier avec
les expertises psychiatriques et
psychologiques ont été rendues voilà
c'est un gamin s'en était un jeu
maternelle sont j'étais âge maternel qui
s'est un peu construit tout seul crée
des établissements qui l'a fréquenté là
encore c'est pas faire c'est pas pour
faire pleurer dans les chaumières que je
dis ça mais c'est une réalité
c'est là dessus qu'il a construit sa
personnalité c'est dans ce cadre là
qu'il a construit sa personnalité
et voilà c'est un élément à prendre en
compte au moment où les jurés devront
décider de sa peine les motivations des
deux accusés sont encore assez floues
même si hier soir il déclarait que
c'était pour faire comme à la télé une
déclaration qui a laissé l'assistance
sans voix les deux accusés encourent
tout de même la prison à perpétuité